good organizer
for having me here
so uh
what i'm going to talk about today is
going to be the first part is really
going to be about ideas from spectral
theory but mostly to learn functions and
in the second part a bit of a look to
more geometric ideas
it's going to be part you know something
old or something new a bit of it is just
reviews of work done in the past that we
will start to work again on recently
and the core of the idea is the line of
work that we did a while ago
with uh oops with ernesto de vito and
andre caponetto from italy and around
the same time um
steve's mail and being schwanzo you know
worked on related idea i guess yuan
who's here was also partially involved
in this kind of ideas where we developed
a bunch of tools and concepts that we
used in several ways
and so today i would like to give you a
highlight of how this idea
the main tools in here and possible
application
uh just to set the stage of the kind of
stuff have in mind
um
the kind of problem we mind i think the
prototype plumbing is signal
classification so the goal here is you
have the high dimensional input vectors
and you want to say classify them in two
classes this is a simple example where
you have
we have spaces and not faces this is the
matrix so
the key point is here that in current
application n is big and p is big and i
don't know which one is bigger here put
millions hundred thousand but it's big
and big okay that's kind of the
situation where we're dealing right now
i have in mind application like the one
the cash was talking about on wednesday
so you can view this as a high
dimensional statistical problem uh just
one observation to me was important is a
the goal here is regeneration so to
predict new data
and perhaps with respect to other line
of research the the measurements here
are not generic in the sense they are
not just random gaussian numbers okay
they're extremely related to each other
and in a very non-linear way and that's
one very important point another
important point that the relation
between the input and the output is also
typically highly non-linear okay so
these are kind of the rule of the game
so some of the ideas say related to
compressed sensing don't fit immediately
in this kind of framework essentially
because of these two requirements
in this context
i think you know to me the two main
challenges are on the one hand try to
see how you can parametrize function in
a good way or equivalently represent the
data and i'm not going to talk about
that but that's part of the whole deep
learning craze is part of that is
because they provide pretty good
features
what i'm going to talk about is another
aspect which is this idea of how to do
inference or statistical model which is
computationally efficient okay
and what i'm going to point at today
goes more in that direction
so i'm going to start giving you a short
video of some of kind of classical
concentration of inverse problems and
these are actually really classical so
i'm just going to try to be go a bit
quickly over them assuming that at least
to some form they're familiar to
some of you and then i'm going to just
try to apply them okay and what we see
that when you apply then you get
something some things that we already
know instantly that we already know and
kind of a unified view
and so i'm going to apply this to
learning function and then see some
other applications okay
so uh
what's an inverse problem well it's
basically defined by this kind of linear
equations
matrix operator doesn't really matter
for now the key point is that a is known
and let's say for a second that g is
known and what you have to find is f
okay so here is the picture there is a
solution space a data space and what
might happen is it's a bunch of bad
things one is that the g might not
belong to the range of a so that there
is no f that can be mapped into g
or a might actually map more than one
thing in the same place so it's not
injected so even if there is one there
might be more than one solution but
perhaps the worst thing is that
you don't really have g in most
application and the classical model is
you have a vector g delta which is a far
away uh at most delta from the
kind of data you like to retrieve
and what might happen is that
uh what you want to improve the behavior
of the solution which is somewhat stable
respect to delta okay if you change that
a little bit you will get something
which is not completely different and
this is related to the behavior of if
you want the inverse which might not be
bounded or even if it's bounded to the
product of these two quantities the
smallest and bigger the condition number
okay so this is like the classical
perspective
so
how do people think about these kind of
problems
well
the first thing is
in some sense if the g doesn't belong to
the range you have no clue
it's hopeless to find a solution so what
you do is that basically you say i'm
going to take this g i'm going to
project it on the range and then i'm
going to find the solution on the other
side there might be more than one i take
the one with minimum norm okay and
that's what this is called the more per
solution or generalized solutions so the
first thing you do is if there exists no
solution i will find one possible
solution that is going to be my target
of the problem okay
but the next step is that now if you
plug here you see i put g the through
uh data if you now plug the the actual
noisy data
this guy might not have uh a stable
behavior with respect to the noise the
noisy date okay so what you do is that
the classical thing is do they think of
regularization okay so you now replace
this with the
penalized minimization which is now a
family of possible solution indexed over
lambda and you have to choose this
lambda depending on the noise
in such a way that this problem gives
you a reasonable solution to the
original problem okay i'm assuming that
everybody is uh
familiar with this
okay so and this is just my starting
point okay so if you look at the
literature in recent years there has
been
this has been like the starting point of
a ginormous amount of extensions and a
lot of extension related to a replacing
this cost function with more general
cost functions perhaps coming from some
kind of probabilistic interpretation in
terms of likelihood or generalizing
these norms to a variety of different
norms okay but the starting point has
always been this kind of penalization
functional
so
what i'm going to describe you next is a
kind of a spectral perspective on this
kind of algorithm which somewhat
suggests that other way to think about
algorithms or if you want estimators
when we do statistics which is not
penalization but it's something else
okay and it's going to be first in a
simplified setting the linear setting
and then giving pointers to how you can
extend this idea
so and the key point here so i'm sorry
my slides are all
cropped with stuff because we just turn
into a pdf so instead of appearing
pieces by pieces you just see everything
so there's no suspense here okay i'm
gonna cover with my body here
so the key point in giving the spectral
perspective on this kind of algorithm is
write down the
singular value composition of the
operator a okay so we assume that
operator a is compact or just assume
that it's finite dimensional take that's
vd okay and this is the sv decomposition
then as soon as you write this the
decomposition you can write down what is
the minimum solution and it's just this
okay
and what you see is that the instability
really comes from the presence of this
one over sigma j you divide i'm just
writing down the projection of g over
this svd of the operator a and this is
your problem okay and this operator here
is what is called the pseudo inverse
so now tikkun of
simply replace this one over sigma j
with this quantity
okay and this quantity here is just says
you
if in some sense if if lambda is much
bigger than sigma j this is overcome and
it's going to dominate if c lambda is
very small essentially you get the same
thing you get here okay so
this is the same thing is before just a
spectral perspective on it
and the way you want to think about this
is as a filter okay you view this as
component of a function something like
fourier components on this just on this
bases ordered with respect to the
eigenvalues so the first few components
are the big eigenvalues and the first
three components of all eigenvalues and
what this is doing is that that's a low
pass filter
unstable components related to small
eigenvalue will be dumped out and the
one which are big enough
are gonna actually preserved okay
so the idea of
spectral filtering regularization is
basically saying how about we replace
this with
another filter function okay so what i
did in this equation is just that i
replaced one over sigma j plus lambda
with another filter function okay
they're called f line
the way you should think about this
filter function is some function that
behaves roughly like this one okay and
the question is are there other examples
of filter function that are interesting
what do they correspond to what kind of
computation they have what kind of
algorithm with what kind of guarantees
you can derive okay
notice that once you define a filter
function
at least in principle immediately you
have some kind of operator okay like a
regularization operator you know already
what this is for tikkun of okay there is
an a-star missing here okay that's
exactly what you have and here you have
some others okay
and the one anticipating things a bit
one main point here is that i'll define
different filter function and not all of
them will need to you know will require
svd to be computed and so this would be
like one highlight
of this kind of methods
so what's a good filter function so this
is going to be the kind of algorithms i
want to introduce these are linear in
the sense that they act linearly on the
g delta okay they're just matrices
acting on this guy
and so
the typical idea is again i can here i
am writing formal but you can formalize
exactly the axioms that gives you what
kind of filters are admissible to define
good linear regularization and here i
just give you a feeling so when lambda
is small it should get you back one over
sigma okay think of t okay just take
these two properties and make them into
actions
and if you look at the soup of this
function
you can view this essentially the soup
norm of the operator norm of the filter
function and you would basically like
this to be controlled by lambda exactly
what happened tikkanov okay if lambda is
small or big this controls the condition
number
of this quantity here okay
make sense
so
three examples
ticonov okay
this is what is called tsvd okay simply
what you do is that you keep one over
sigma if sigma is bigger than lambda
otherwise you throw it away another way
to say this is just enumerate the
singular values and keep the first m
okay and the other you just throw away
the last one is this guy here
okay i don't know if you've seen it
before again it's something it's
completely obvious if you've seen it
but to observation what is this well
think about it as a truncated series
expansion okay so c take sigma to the
minus one
write it as a power expansion
okay this would be an equality and now
you just truncate
okay so this parameter t here i should
have put it here the t is really lambda
here okay
so the number of the only there are two
three parameters there is a gamma here
and there is a t here gamma you should
just choose as a constant so that this
series converge if you let t goes to
infinity okay so think of gamma as a
constant that depends on sigma the free
parameter is only this guy
and the more
t the more you get close to the higher
is t the more you get close to one over
sigma
okay
so
each of these immediately define an
algorithm okay and if you stop here
basically the game would be
take your matrix do the svd plug this
guy inside and check if these filters
are any one you know one is better than
the other but computationally you would
have to do as video in every case
okay and this is not too appealing
but for example for tickle we know that
we have a bunch of different kind of
techniques to do it okay so one question
is is there another way to implement
this kind of filters is some of them can
be done without actually advocating an
svd and this is well known to be
possible
so the one i want to show you is this
one here so again now i wrote it so this
is just think of lambda as one over t
okay that's exactly the kind of uh
association you need
so the key point here is that just look
at this iteration
okay if you run it for t times
at step t you get exactly the solution
you would get if you were to compute the
svd and plug in this expression
that make sense
so
suppose that you plug here
this expression
and then you build this operator then
you get the function okay
instead of doing this way
what i'm telling you is that you can
prove and it's a one-line induction
proof that if you run this these steps
you get the same thing
okay
so this in some sense is that this is
the cute aspect of this story that to
compute some of these and in particular
these iterative regularization
techniques you don't need to in some
sense do the svd but you can run an
iteration okay and in a couple of slides
i'm going to show you the complexity and
three this one will be much much much
better okay
and you can say oh this is simple but
this idea can be generalized in a bunch
of ways so you know i'm emphasizing this
a bit because
if you look for example universe
problems
this is the algorithm of choice in the
most large scale application nobody
would end up doing you know a teacup
regularization you would actually
essentially apply conjugate gradient and
then realize that conjugate gradient or
anything like that is enough and you
don't have to regularize in any other
way you can just stop the number of
iterations okay
so two more comments again this is an
iteration that you stop okay and t is
the precision of your approximation
gamma here the step size just comes from
the idea that you need to have this
series converging so it's a constant and
this is the number you have to pick you
need to know the spectral radius of your
of your problem
and of course you can just view this as
gradient descent this is just the
gradient of the risk unregularized so
there is no explicit penalization to the
problem okay
and i think uh
if you want i think
lorenzo might you know
sometimes uh talk about implicit
regularization to me you know
i don't know what implicit regulation
really means i just need some example i
think this is one good example okay it's
a good example of one case where i can
actually view it in two different ways
this is essentially equivalent to
ticking off but it's actually use a life
of its own right okay and in some sense
the key point here is that computations
and regularization coincide
just one example this is not yet
learning but just you know simple
interpolation problem the noisy problem
we have a bunch of points fixed and some
noise you just what is the idea here
here this gives you a justification in
terms of matrix inversion but you can
also just use now this algorithm and you
can just say i start fitting
i start from zero and if i fit too much
i start to follow the noise but ideally
if i stop before i will get something
which gets rid of the noise okay so
now that you have this perspective you
could also pursue this perspective
further and this would be the way to go
beyond these squares essentially
okay so this little uh hopefully not too
boring
review of some idea of universe problem
was meant to essentially give you a
feeling that
there are principles other than
penalization that you can define them
rigorously and will be in some sense all
different phases of the same idea which
is this ideo doing filtering on the
spectrum
and the kind of nice idea is this
observation that not only the different
principles so essentially projections
iteration and penalization are different
phases of the same idea but they have
different computational properties
note in passes that if you look at the
literature inverse problem there are a
bunch of extension of the on the setting
i showed you okay for example the noise
can be taken to be stochastic the
operator itself can be taken to be noisy
you can generalize from compact
operators and so on and so forth and of
course also in that case people
generalize to different costs and
different norms okay but i want to stick
to
this kind of l2 norm regularization and
i'll comment on that in a little bit
that's a good question
so um if you go back to the original
regularized view
typically it will put like a weight in
front of your regular riser how is that
coming into play here
oh each of these algorithm as it's so
you talk about uh
the derivation parameter this guy the
lambda there each of this algorithm has
its own okay so each of this filter has
a parameter lambda that exactly like so
that
that in some sense so you can do it in
two ways it that controls the fitting
the smoothing trade-off so
it's just this guy the usual
in svd is just a cut off yes the
important thing is that in this case is
the number of components you take but
you also have a gamma right
is a constant it's a number it's a
number that i choose to be one over a
square and now the question you can ask
me is could i actually run this
infinitely many time and pick this to be
a resolution parameter yes but in some
sense right now i'd rather do the other
thing because if i fix this then i can
do much like the cool thing here is that
if i fix this now i can't do fewer
iterations because i will do just enough
computation
to discover what's the signal in the
data
but that's an important point that the
the revision parameter here is the
number of iterations
i had there's some intuition that this
is related like a for a transform of
your data or something and you're
keeping certain frequencies you prefer
the low but not and but not too much or
so exactly so they're they're special so
in this case you essentially use
guy the
the composition of the operator as if it
was a fourier series
okay and then you can think about it
exactly in this case so if this is just
uh say a diffusion operator over some
domain with some boundary condition you
do get fourier series and that's exactly
what you're doing and i'm just telling
you to implement the low pass filter run
an iteration
and this is where you keep all the
frequencies with the same
same weight
yeah so i ordered the frequency to from
higher to lower so
and then i just keep the first
truncation it's just a loop
okay yeah it's just a lupus filtering
view on this
is this frankie it's kind of
you know
your carbon kit is power method in some
sense yeah is that a way to get
virtualization that corresponds to
translating consciousness which is what
people are actually
doing now let me comment on that in a
little bit so the short answer is
essentially
so you can do two things okay because
clearly this can say
notice two things so you can say oh this
is low okay i don't want to do this but
you can also ask okay but i don't want
to converge anyway so is this going to
be important yes it's going to be
important you can speed it up in two
different ways one is to do conjugate
gradient and this is going to become
almost this but it's not the linear
method anymore or you can do some kind
of acceleration
which is more or less we have the master
of kind of stuff and you still get the
linear method so you can still study in
this framework and then at the point
essentially i'll show you exactly what
happens so essentially the square root
of the number of iterations stuff is two
to get where you need to go so you can
do that
mr d i was expecting gamma to be say two
times one over two times the normal
array as opposed to normal squared
or just this guy this guy here if you
look
acts on a star a
so this is the singular values and this
is the eigenvalue so the singular value
is square root of sigma
but here you have to put square root
times square root
so it's just the it's just what it does
so sigma
is the eigenvalue of this
so if you want i could put here
a normal-based array
okay
so
learning okay there is a learning is in
the in the in the background so i'm
going to just consider this standard
setting so it's a regression you know
non-parametric random design regression
setting
so i have x and y i have a regression
function
and for this equal simplification i'm
just going to assume that my output are
bounded okay i could relax to say
gaussian assumption and so on but i
don't want to do it
and and under this assumption let me
introduce immediately this norm i'm a
bit sloppy raw is actually the norm on
the space x and this is just the norm a
natural norm associated to this
probability distribution it puts weights
on points that are more likely to be
sampled
okay
and the regression function is easy to
see that it belongs there
this is all fixed but unknown all you
have in your data and now given the data
you want to find an approximation of
this
okay now the question is is there an
inverse problem here
so you can say conceptually something
like that is happening there is a model
then there is some sampling then i want
to go back but i want an operator and i
want to be able you know to touch these
objects so i can just plug in in the
previous expressions okay and this is
going to cost me a bit of sweat
so bear with me for a few slides
it's easy if you take
a linear model just consider a linear
model forget about this k for a second
just consider a linear model okay and
just take the data they find a
dimensional case that then it's very
easy to write down an inverse problem
you basically say i'm going to assume
that my function can be written as or
i'm going to try to find the linear
function that fits my data and i write
down these linear equations okay
i might find a good w i might not find
it but i can just write this linear
system and if i write it in matrix
notation so if i pile up all my y and
all the vectors of x into matrix this is
just an n by d matrix the data matrix
applied to w and it gives me y okay so
this is a map that goes from rd to rn
so this is okay you can just do this and
you could start to apply things over
there but if you want to do theory you
have to ask yourself this is this
corresponds to the noisy situation okay
these data are sampled and noisy
the ideal problem is where you have no
samples and no noise so can we write
down a similar equation
that would correspond to the ideal case
what is it okay
anything which is up here should have no
sampling and no noise
and
one one
this is going to be a bit formal
if you look at rn as the function l2
with respect to the empirical measure
you can recognize one and to the other
so if you took the empirical image this
is an atomic measure and function are
just vectors
you know the function value are just you
can see as a component of a vector okay
so
at that point you can actually replace
the empirical measure with the true
measure and just rebuild everything and
in some sense instead of i from one over
n you get that this has to be true for
any x in your support that you might
sample and instead of y you actually get
f row which is the average okay it's the
somewhat the the noiseless version of y
and the operator is a bit funny so how
do you read this equation you're saying
i have a regression function and i'm
looking for a linear function which best
approximate my regression function for
any possible points that i can pick up
from my distribution okay
and you can immediately introduce an
associated operator which is just acting
on the function producing this okay so
now you can do this as an ideal setting
and this as a noisy setting okay you can
apply the algorithm here and then try to
show that theoretically you can go back
here
okay
but
what i want to do is
go beyond linear models okay and i'm
going to use kernels essentially because
they provide me a general way they might
be important in practice or not
depending on the kind of kernels you use
let me remind you that the key point in
my talk is going to be that i'm going to
look at instead of just linear function
as a hebrew space of functions it has
these two problems there is a special
function k of xx
such that if i fix one of the two
entries this function is in the space
and this helped me to write down f of x
through this inner product okay
this is all i need
and you can view this as a
generalization of writing things in a
linear as a linear
function where this is the weights and
this is x okay this is a
abstract way to look at the same
equation
and just two examples
if you take any dictionary of any size
okay no assumptions
this is going to be a kernel
you can do this as whenever you're
taking your data and you map them you
get a kernel okay it's there whether you
use it or not it's there
or you can have stuff like the gaussian
kernel other kind of currents that you
don't directly can view in this way you
might not have access to a
parameterization like this okay
so let me just do a kind of a bit
more abstract step and then i try to
explain it what is the idea well just
take what we've done now
okay and then just replace
with uh
k x with kx and w with f and this is
what you get you get these two equations
okay
remember that this gives me f at x so
this is basically find an f which at x i
is equal to y i and here it says find an
f that at every point x give me a good
approximation of the throw
okay
this problem both of them can be imposed
okay it might be that a fro
it's not a linear function or in this
case that it doesn't belong to the
kernel i took i take the polynomial
kernel and my function is whatever it's
it's
not continuous okay so all these can be
opposed and plus i sample and i put
noise
we can stop here i just wanted to
mention a slightly more geometric point
of view to interpret these operators
that give some insight
this is basically a point of view that
was suggested by koi manila phone a few
years ago
if you look at the suppose now the
interesting case to look at this
operator is the one where
x is the ambient space
and m is the support of your input
distribution okay
and what we are and so this is just a 2d
case so my data have two dimensions but
really they lie on a one-dimensional
surface which i call m okay and y now is
the function values
this is a regular situation we think it
happens in practice okay it might not be
a manifold it might not be a set but
certainly is not the full space it's not
a fully supported distribution
then in this case you can view the
effect of this operator as a restriction
okay so the function in h are defined
everywhere here
so when i apply this operator i'm just
restricting them to the point that come
from this m
okay
if you look at the joint of this
operator you can do it as an extension
operator you have a function that you
know has values only here
but you're going to define it everywhere
else
okay
and you can prove that this operator in
some sense are the one that has minimal
distortion of the two norms
here and here so in some sense the
minimum norm it
extension of the function
if you write this case if you replace
the true set okay with the data what you
get is an operator the restriction
operator you can use a sampling operator
given a function you evaluate it at the
points
and it's a joint it becomes something
that is actually pretty useful input
which is the out of sample extension so
now
c is a vector and you can view it as
function values at points and now you
extend it everywhere because look at
this equation this holds for any x okay
so now you have this value function at
points
and then you sum them up and this is for
any x and these will give you a value of
a function at any x okay there is a
mistake here this should be s star
c
okay so this is for any x so i'm
extending the function values from the
trinity points everywhere
okay
uh
okay so this is the backflip this is the
setup but once you have this you can
just turn the crank and apply the
algorithms
so you get this if you have a finite
parameterization of f this is what you
get and if you look at the complexity
here i write the complexity comprising
the fact that we might want to compute
this for more than one lambda and here
is the comparison between the three
methods and
the the the quick inspection showed that
essentially the iterative method is the
winner by far between this guy okay
is the one that gives you the best
possible computation of course now you
can say well how did you solve tecon you
could have done conjugate gradient yes
but i'm doing it here i only do it once
so to some extent why would i want to do
it more than once for different values
of lambdas okay so a key point here is
if you know lambda or if you have to
look for different kind of lambdas and
in practice oftentimes you need to have
to search for more than one solution
now
if
this function doesn't have a finite
dimensional parameterization you can
play this trick essentially you can
you can basically show that the function
always every presentation of this form
is a represented form of the representer
theorem and reduce the problem to just
computing coefficients
over this finite dimensional problem k
here is just a kernel matrix it's an n
by n matrix okay and so now you just
have to apply the filter function on the
spectrum of the empirical kernel matrix
and to prove it is really just one line
of linear there's something nothing deep
but in some sense here you know that you
can always like either work in some
sense in the primal if you can
or in some form of duel where the
dimension of the space doesn't matter
anymore
and you can ask yourself what's the
complexity it changes a bit instead of
md essentially you got n square plus the
price of computing the kernel matrix
that is basically what you have okay and
again this algorithm will give you much
better complexity of the other two
especially of the fact that we because
of this one restart properties the more
steps you take the more or less you
regularize
so
some of these studies know some of this
stuff is not known some of this stuff
has been rediscovered or discovered in
several occasions of course tikonov
ridge regression is very old
more recently they've been called least
squarespace vector machine tsvd can just
be seen as a form of principal component
usage of principal component analysis in
supervised and it's called principal
component regression
and for example uh sean has some recent
results where he was looking at some
five dimensional case of this
the iteration has been called delto
boosting and introduced by in statisti
by
bing yoo and peter booman a few years
ago and has been studying even recently
and the list can keep on going okay
conjugate gradient turns out to be
equivalent to what is identical
partially squares and you can have a
theory for that and then you can move on
and this kind of acceleration you can
try to think about incremental methods
and hear the list especially if you go
and explore
uh
different iteration schemes very long
okay and you can ask yourself which one
works best in practice which one you can
prove something
so quickly about theory i'm gonna i will
not want to skip these slides but just
to give you an idea i'm throwing i want
to study the statistical properties of
this method and i'm throwing away
eigenvalues okay that's essentially what
my algorithm is doing so
if my function if not many eigenvalues
are different from zeros
or my function can be really well
written on those eigenvalues on those
eigen functions then the algorithm is
gonna work so i have this two parameter
okay how many eigen values i have
different from zero how many components
of my function are different from zero
okay and in the standard fixed design
setting this is exactly what comes out
in this more general setting you have
similarly two parameters they're called
source condition or degrees of
imposedness or freedom okay and instead
of just a number you can also take a
decay okay instead of saying they they
are
n and then zero you can just get they
have a certain profile
and this allows you to get the theory
both for the infinite dimension and the
finite dimensional case
a long story short what you have is that
if you do take this kind of decay
condition for all the methods you get
this result
okay and if you take the
finite finiteness assumption so the if
you assume your space to be finite
dimensional this is what you get
okay
so the using to to notice is this this
boundary essentially optimal up to
constant okay and the filter function
only enters as a constant
or as the range of possible smoothness
that you can allow in your problem okay
tikkanov is blind to smoothness up to a
certain order there's a known effect
called saturation okay and so you don't
improve results after a certain point
so this is a
this will be weird and to some extent
the old algorithm at exactly the same
statistical properties up to constant
okay now constant might matter but to a
level they all act in this exact in the
same way they have all the same minimax
rates
you can
find different way to do adaptivity you
can find finite dimension
but in some sense the natural question
to me now is if i now i give you this
class of minimax uh problems what is the
best computational complexity you can
get on this kind of problems okay and
here i show you that my
my benchmark is certainly not economics
these iterative methods whose complexity
i wrote before
is
this okay
so
i would like to know is there other
other other
algorithm achieving minimax rates with
complexity better than this okay and of
course a key point here is how do you
choose lambda what kind of algorithm you
do if you do hold out and you don't have
much overhead if you have to do an svd
to choose lambda because for example you
want to do complexity regularization and
use some kind of penalty then this kills
this complexity okay so how do you
choose lambda matters
uh
just a side remark you might think that
you know this is the theory is for free
is not quite because
these operators have different domain
and so you cannot just compare them okay
you have to introduce some other notion
of noise which are not the canonical one
in inverse problem and it turns out that
this is actually the natural thing you
have to do when you have to study
discretization problems so bridging
somewhat with fields like pdes where in
some sense you have a continuous case
and you want to discretize it but it
also gives you a way to look at if you
have a discrete problem you want to do
some sampling you can just plug it in
here and you have a result for that kind
of situation okay where instead of a
continuous distribution you have a
discrete distribution but with a very
large support and now you wanna
subsample it okay so these are relative
quantity that will appear there too
so a few comments
i guess
the main one as i said is it does give
me this way of thinking a bit more
competition into regularization and that
to me is very inspiring of other tricks
i could use and now whenever time i said
somebody tell me a trick that you use to
make this computation faster or more
stable i will
feel like sitting down and figure out if
i can view it as some kind of
regularization and avoid repeating
things twice okay
and as i said i think this is exactly
kind of the intuition besides behind
that
the interview regularization emerged
kind of the algorithm of choice so
natural question is can i do it for
other loss functions okay and the answer
is yes can i do it well well i don't
know we just started can you do it for
the regularizers okay i think you won as
a recent paper i know for example total
variation you can do it is a standard
case can you do it for l1 there are some
results we are doing some results for
learning
and the other thing is that there is a
whole bunch of tricks as i said for
example you know we discussed with then
right that you're using random features
and it was his idea it was mostly
listening he was you do block coordinate
descent with random features it turns
out that you can do it this way or you
can divide your data set okay in blocks
and then average out this is another way
of doing a randomized filter and you can
keep on going you can do some kind of
incremental mainstream and keep on going
and this is in the attempt to break the
complexity barrier below essentially
this and the complex
okay
so quickly how much time i have zero two
minutes
nine minutes okay
so
let me just try to show you quickly if
this one slides about
something else
just one comment
take what i told you okay and for
example just replace the output with the
i i did everything for real values okay
do it for rt or for a hilbert space this
is into it for multitask or for
functional regression nothing change
okay it's all the same
it's for free
and in fact the minor modification of
this allows you to actually consider
situation where you do some kind of
noisy density estimation the
convolutional problem that we use using
to study so-called regularized kernel
mean and bending
uh
misha has been using this in this
problem that because inverse density
estimations there is some ideas related
to base inference in this perspective
and so on and so forth so this same idea
can apply in all the setting and will be
in some sense you do start from tikkanov
and i can come in and just tell you just
do this other stuff which might be
computationally more efficient okay and
if they're equivalent essentially
the other thing you can do is move on
and somewhat take this other point of
view where you know that has been one of
the main theme of this workshop this
idea that spectral properties of certain
operators yield information about the
geometry of sets
and here i just want to you know just
catch one example of something we did a
while ago it's a very simple question
and it's essentially the problem of
estimating the set the distribution
sorry the support of the distribution
okay so i know that my sample comes from
some set and i want to estimate the set
and this is related to the problem also
called novelty detection or
problem of surface modeling and i would
like to understand more specifically if
the eigen function or the spectral
structure of the integral operator
itself
rather than some other quantity related
to it like a laplacian or other thing
related to this operator can yield
information about this set okay i
basically want to go from exactly from
the original space into the spectral
properties of an operator or function of
the space
so i take an abstract setting but
the highlights are essentially that this
is an unsupervised problem i have data i
have a distribution and i have some
kernel okay and then i'm given some data
and i would like to estimate the support
of the distribution aside from details
this is my problem okay so i have the
support and i sample it i would like to
get it back according to some norms or
metric over sets
so here was the idea
so
i guess some of you are familiar with
the mercedes theorem or cargo of an
expansion and so on and it basically
says the following
if
you consider this integral operator with
kernel k over probability measure rho
then you can expand the k in this way
okay
and this is a well-known fact a detail
in this thing is that the proof that
dates back 100 years ago ask the support
of the distribution to be the whole
space
okay and to be compact
which is not a very natural situation
you're learning because this is a
probability distribution
it's measure one it's not le beg like it
was done 100 years ago
and so in fact you can generalize this
theorem but basically asking
the support to be whatever it is let me
call it m
and this to be continuous but bounded
okay
the key point is that this expression
here doesn't look for any xx prime it
only holds for the xx prime from the
support
okay
if x and x prime come from the support i
have this expression
so the curiosity was what if i take
in particular of course i can take x
prime equal to x okay
now the curiosity was what happens if i
take a point which is not in the support
do i have this equality or not so if i
take an x which is not in the support
does these quality holes or not
what is the catch here suppose that it
holds if and only if the point in the
support
then i could try to compute the quantity
like this and use it as a test
to
to determine whether points belong to
the support or not okay
of course if this is not a
characterization of the support that's
not possible
long story short
it's not true for any kernel okay there
are certain kernels that are rich enough
that you can actually have this
one-to-one correspondence between
support
and
mercy fear and mercy theory becomes a
test there are other kernels which are
not good enough and essentially the
kernel are
kernel such that for a given set that
you can find functions that are zero on
the set and noon zero everywhere else
okay so essentially bump functions there
have to be a space of function which are
not too smooth
so it's easy to convince yourself that
certain currents will be fine for
certain kind of sets but if the set is
complicated certain color will not fail
if the set
so if this is x and this is m if you
take the linear kernel you can find the
hyperplane with exactly zero here and so
that would be enough
but if you take a set of this form
which is just a piece of an upper plane
then the
hyperplane will keep on putting zero
also here so this simple linear kernel
will not be enough okay which is
intuitive the kernel is to be flexible
enough to be able to
zero out everything but the support
you can ask yourself if there are kernel
in at least in rd that can separate any
set okay and the sort answer is yes and
they have to be noon smooth enough and
for example the gaussian kernel doesn't
work it's analytic as soon as it's zero
in one portion of the space you have to
be zero all around it and so you won't
be able to separate the set
appropriately
now
i'm almost done essentially the point
here is that if
the set is separated by k or if k
separates any set in which case it will
be true then this is a one to one
correspondence
the point in the support are exactly the
one for which this equality holds okay
and then you can use it you can use it
as a merced test okay you take it you do
it
and the key point here
is let me be quick essentially these are
the eigen functions you can imagine that
in some sense you have to decompose the
the
you can try to use the technology i
showed you before the idea here is that
computing this quantity when sigma
becomes small will be an unstable
procedure so i might want to cut off
this expression when you have finite
data and essentially you can realize
that you can rewrite this in terms of
integral operator
and roughly speaking replace the
integral operator with empirical
integral operator then you get the
kernel matrix and you keep on going and
you get
an inverse that you have to stabilize
and blah blah blah blah and you can
apply exactly the kind of techniques i
showed you before filters and so on and
you get a new family of one one class
algorithm or support estimation
algorithm that are iterative and all the
properties i showed you before okay
of course the theory is different this
is not a supervised problem anymore i
now have to understand what's going on
and i'm going to skip basically all this
you can prove consistency but no rates
in household distance
you get pretty good empirical results
and it was one step in the direction of
understanding how the properties
spectral probabilities kind of
convolution integral operator is
information about
geometric information about the set
itself okay
and this is basically what i wanted to
say so the again to me the key point
here i really this idea that
beyond penalization i can try to use
other principles and then i can try to
apply them and in some sense think
whatever computational trick you do if
it yields some way to stabilize your
problem
and the other direction which i'm very
cruise about now is push this iterative
regularization perspective and see to
which extent i can use it as a default
mechanism which would be useful for
other learning problems okay
and last but not least this idea which
is just at the beginning of
studying integral operators and geometry
if you've seen what i've just said i
don't assume any manifold structure or
anything okay it's just a set okay so
one one question is how much when we
push it
all right
question
can you say something about like
how do i ask you like i'm gonna find out
is that
is that part of the problem right i'm
missing that
in this last case you mean yeah in the
last case
well in the end basically like what i do
is that
i take this equation vis-a-vis this
requires knowledge of the distribution
when you have data
replace these eigen functions with some
eigenfunction that you out of sample
extension of eigenfunction you compute
on your data set okay and it was a bit
quick but essentially this is what you
need to do
so ins
instead of using this function
you can now use a completely empirical
function
but what might happen at this point that
you need a tolerance okay so you have to
say
how much these equality is violated and
you have two parameters this global
parameter and this local parameter so
this behind my set estimate okay
so top decreases as sample size
increases yes
exactly
and they're not unconditional i mean
some say this is the weak part of this
theory again it was just a bit at the
beginning we don't have super sharp
rates or super sharp geometric
understanding of that
so so it seems like there should be some
variant where you uh
deprecate the eigenvalues by an
exponential
yeah something like the heat equation
but yeah you did that somewhere or and i
missed it or no i did not
i did not so the thing i don't know is
uh
it makes perfect sense the one thing i
don't know is uh
can you can we show that that that has a
good computational
implementation okay
and so in some sense the easy part is
can you just put it i would say yes we
can just probably put it in and just
show it as properties the question is
can we avoid doing the svd to compute it
and that is actually i don't know and i
think it's the
hard part of the story
yeah you think you use something like
the stuff that lorenzo yeah break your
work done and different exponentials
right then yeah i i think it makes sense
i've not done it and i don't think
anybody has done it in some sense
exactly once you know this you know
bring in all your tricks and try to see
if you can fit i just give you my best
and a way to think about it and just
speed me